(upbeat, industrial music)
- Working out has been
a huge part of my life.
I try to do it as much as I can,
at least three times a week.
- I'll do, usually, three days of cardio,
and three days of strength.
- I'm a competitive CrossFitter.
I work out ten or 11 hours a week.
- For the last four years,
I've been an Olympic weightlifter.
- Hopefully I don't, I don't pass out.
- I don't want to get runner's diarrhea.
- What if I trip? What
I'm not fast anymore?
What if I'm too old?
- Best-case scenario, I
beat all the other girls.
Worst-case scenario, I fail completely
and make a fool out of myself.
(ominous, orchestral music)
- The physical fitness
test is administered
according to very strict FBI protocols.
- Event one, sit-ups to
be done in one minute.
Event two, 300-meter dash.
Event three, push-ups to
be done without stopping.
Event four, one and a half mile run.
(repetitive, authoritative
orchestral music)
- You got it.
- Oh my god. Ah!
That was way harder than I thought.
(soft, modest music)
- Sit-ups for time is a lot harder
than I thought it would be.
- I think I did it right.
I was bouncing pretty hard off the ground.
I think I got some momentum from that.
- It wasn't too bad.
I was very focused
throughout and I feel like
I'm ready for the next challenge.
- I went through a range of
emotions, like I'd be like,
"I'm crushing it! Oh my god
there's so much time left!
Oh, now I'm slowing... Now
I'm crushing it again!"
(determined, instrumental music)
(background cheers)
(encouraging remarks)
(soft, pulsing music)
- I went fast out of the gate
and then I was like, this is a bad idea.
- We got to the half-way mark
and Candace goes, "I'm dying."
- I felt good, like I went out
kind of easier --
- Yeah.
- and then just turned it on.
- Right.
- But pretty close, I was like,
am I even running in a
straight direction anymore?
(escalating, epic orchestral music)
(soft, tingling percussion)
- It was pretty easy, because apparently
FBI push-ups are only
half the range of motion
compared to the push-ups I normally do.
- Maybe if I did the correct
form it would have been harder.
But since I just like
(laughs) screwed it up,
I think it was pretty easy.
- It felt really different,
because I normally
do my push-ups really close here.
So I felt them a lot in a
different part of my arm.
- I have a weak upper body,
and I knew that this wasn't gonna be fun.
(escalating, epic orchestral music)
(soft, pulsing music)
- I think that slope, that
first slope really hit me
in my glutes and I felt like
I wasn't going to make it,
but I kept a consistent pace and
having the music was really
helpful to get through it.
- At some point I had to
stop and walk a little,
but then instead of getting defeated,
I remembered how when I
did marathon training,
that even a short rest gives
you so much more energy
and then I was able to take
off and finish the run.
- I'm actually very
shocked that I did that
in that amount of time
because I usually run
like a ten-minute mile.
I think I was just terrified of failing.
- Man, that first hill was so steep,
and I was never the same again.
But that being said, this was actually
my fastest mile pace I've run in years.
(soft instrumental music)
- So, I passed. I feel good about it.
I'm slightly surprised.
I really thought I was going to fail
on that mile and a half run,
so I'm glad that I didn't.
- I'm kinda proud of myself.
I think I did pretty well.
- The FBI fitness test
wasn't as challenging as
I thought it was gonna be.
- But it does make me a little sad
that I was able to crush the FBI test,
and makes you wonder if they shouldn't
have a little higher benchmark.
- Now that I've passed it,
I kinda feel unstoppable.
I feel like I should be in a
James Bond movie or something.
- To celebrate, I'm going
to have some ice cream,
and I'm going to go
work-out in the morning
feeling pretty good about myself.
(plucky instrumental music)